I want to start with this story that's
gotten a lot of attention recently and
here's the report from ESPN
this a couple days ago we'll have the
update in a moment but here's the report
retired NFL star Michael Orr whose
supposed adoption out of grinding
poverty by a wealthy white family was
immortalized in the 2009 movie The Blind
Side
petition at Tennessee Court Monday with
allegations that a central element of
the story was a lie concocted by the
family to enrich itself at his expense
the 14-page petition filed in Shelby
County Tennessee alleges that Sean and
Leanne Tui who took ore into their home
as a high school student never adopted
him claims that they never adopted him
that's the claim
instead less than three months after Orr
turned 18 in 2004 the position says the
couple tricked him into signing a
document making them his conservators
which gave them legal authority to make
business deals in his name petition
further alleges that the twois used
their power as conservators to strike a
deal that paid them and their two birth
children Millions royalties from an
oscar-winning film that earned more than
300 million dollars while Orr got
nothing for a story that would not have
existed without him in the year since
the two ways have continued calling the
37 year old or their adopted son and
have used that assertion to promote
their Foundation as well as Leanne tui's
work as an author and motivational
speaker
quote the legal filing uh quotes the LIE
of Michael's adoption is one upon which
co-conservators Lee antonui have
enriched themselves at the expense of
their award the undersigned Michael Orr
Michael Oher discovered this lie to his
Chagrin and embarrassment in February of
2023 when he learned that the
conservatorship to which he consented on
the basis that doing so would make him a
member of the Tui family in fact
provided him no familiar relationship
with the tuis at all and uh that's the
basic story so the media loves this
story they're so happy about this ESPN
reporters are it's are it's orgasmic for
them they are or in orgasmic Delight
over this story because you have to
understand the media and the left hated
the Michael Oher story they hated The
Blind Side Story because it's a story of
a white family rescuing a black kid from
his abusive and neglectful parents and
giving him a better life
um it's a story in their phrase of a
white Savior and so they hate it now
when the movie first came out a movie
that I didn't particularly particularly
like by the way I thought it was like
cheesy and hammy and I didn't I didn't
like it that much but when it first came
out the media loved it and it won Oscars
and everything like that
um because that was in 2009 before
Barack Obama had a chance to set race
relations back 50 years but in recent
years the leftist started to view this
the movie very differently and now they
hate it
and then Michael Oher comes out and and
what do you know look at that
turns out the media realized suddenly
that the story was actually bad and soon
after that Michael Orr also realized
that the story was bad and went to the
media and said hey by the way you know
you're right it was bad this is all very
bad let me tell you how bad it was and
the media goes oh look at that we were
right that we were right
but maybe we have a narrative and it
just so happens that that it fits right
into the narrative wow that's great
so this already makes me highly
skeptical I mean if you hear about this
story As Told by ESPN or any Outlet like
that
and you accepted at face value then I
don't know what to say you are too
stupid
just in general like you're you need to
not be that stupid stop being stop being
stupid
you need to not be stupid anymore
if you hear a story like this
you'll see many people on social media
including conservatives
sharing this this and I can't believe
that they would do that to him
clearly you know the original reporting
on this story must be absolutely correct
there's nothing to be skeptical about it
at all here and I am shocked and
appalled
no
um any time something allegedly happens
that that seems like the media wished it
into existence you need to take it with
an enormous heap of salt now it doesn't
mean that it's automatically false
just playing the odds like every once in
a while something will really happen in
real life that is that works with the
media narrative most the time they have
to lie to make things fit the narrative
every once in a while just again play
the odds like every once in a while
something will happen that the media
doesn't even need to lie about
and and they'll say well that's nice we
can take a break from lying for uh for
the next 45 seconds
but
um that's very uh rare that's few and
far between and so you gotta be very
skeptical and I am here this one doesn't
pass the smell test at all you know I go
with my gut on these kinds of stories
and I've literally never been wrong okay
I mean it's I'm batting a thousand so
when I since a story like this and it's
race involved and all this like this
kind of thing
uh I go with my gut I make a call I've
never been wrong I've never LED you
astray so when I'm looking at something
like this and I say no this this isn't
right this doesn't sound I've never I
just I've never been wrong and so I'm
telling you and if I'm if this ends up
being the first time I'm wrong about it
then fine but I'm telling you this I'm
not buying it I don't buy it
um and and more is going to come out
about this thing that is going to cast
we're going to start to see it's you
know uh start to see it very differently
that's my prediction
um
and
now that's obviously we know that the
Blind Side
movie is a movie okay so you don't need
to tell me well you know it's not all
correct they're detailed of course it's
not all right it's a movie
I'm not a like I know that
okay it's it's probably 85 percent made
up that's it's based on a true story
usually means like maybe 15 correct
even if they can have two percent
correct they can still say that it's
based on true story
um so that I don't doubt but if you want
to tell me that the two e's are actually
you know and if you want to tell me that
they're not well you know they're not
selfless Heroes it's more complicated
than that I believe that too most people
aren't selfless Heroes most people are
just human beings and uh so that doesn't
surprise me
but
The Narrative we're getting now feels to
me like a Shakedown and it doesn't make
a lot of sense okay uh like he's 37
years old and just found out that he
wasn't adopted he didn't know that
before
at the age of 37 you just how how did
you not know that
also where did anyone ever claim that he
was adopted
now I admit that I haven't watched the
movie in a long time but
I don't think that claim was even made
the ESPN starts their their article how
do they phrase it
um
whose supposed adoption
did they ever claim that he that was
illegally adopted
so
so what's going on here did Michael Oher
squander his NFL money and now he's
turning on this family to try to shake
them down is he going full Kaepernick is
he looking for relevance and attention
does he want another movie deal here's
the real Blind Side Story you know that
kind of thing
um
that to me seems more plausible and then
we get the update this is from the New
York Post Michael Oher the ex-nfl star
whose story inspired the oscar-winning
uh film The Blind Side allegedly asked
his adopted family for 15 million
dollars not to go public with claims
they swindled him according to the
family's attorney
Sean and Leanne Tui said through their
legal Representatives there's no Korean
stores claims that he was fooled into a
conservatorship and rubbished claims the
couple made Millions off his life story
their lawyer told TMZ sports or was
instead the principal offender who has
repeatedly threatened to plant a
negative story about the two he's in the
Press if they didn't cough up an
eight-figure check
attorney Marty singer said over the
years the tuis have given Mr Ward an
equal cut of every penny received from
The Blind Side even recently when a
store started to threaten them about
what he would do unless they paid him an
eight-figure windfall and as part of
that Shakedown effort refused to cash
the small profit checks from the twois
they still deposited Mr Orr's equal
share into a trust account they set up
for his son
so that's that is the now the good thing
is there's this is a dollar and cents
thing much of it so if they get you know
they're saying yeah we gave him plenty
of money
and if that's not true if they're lying
then it'll be easily disproven or it
could be easily proven
if it is true it's like this is one of
those literally show the receipts thing
if they can show the receipts then the
whole claim is bunk by Michael Oher
um
so maybe they're making some kind of
claim publicly that they that is false
and that can be easily disproven I tend
to doubt it
but
this is the version that sounds like
that that lines up with just what makes
sense it's it's the most plausible
version it's exactly what it sounds like
to me have you ever wondered if you
could turn your Tech Obsession into your
profession with the help of the team at
covalence now you can since 2015
covalence has taught thousands of people
of all ages the art of software
development with their new community
membership they're making it easier and
more affordable than ever before for
only 25 bucks a month you can Master
full stack web development they're
comprehensive proven curriculum has a
community-based support with real people
available to help you when you need it
they also have an AI teaching assistant
that could create instant challenges
interactive quizzes and more covalences
less than 83 cents per day it's about
120 times cheaper than your average
college so whether you're looking to
change your career or level up in your
current profession you learn to build
real websites and applications by
actually building them for real get your
first month free with code Walsh by
clicking the link in the description
don't just browse the web build it with
covalence that's promo code Walsh with
the link in the description
with everything going on in the world
right now you could really use a good
night's sleep that's why you need to
check out Helix Matrix Helix has
harnessed years of extensive match
expertise to bring their customers a
truly elevated sleep experience they
just launched their new Helix Elite the
Helix Elite collection includes six
different mattress models each tailored
for specific sleep positions and
firmness preferences I've had my Helix
for years now and I absolutely love it
night after night I sleep like a sweet
sweet baby and I want the same for you
Helix has a sleep quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress because why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else go
to helixsleep.com Walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz to find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type their flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away for a limited time Helix
is giving you 20 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
take advantage of this amazing offer at
helixsleep.com Walsh with Helix better
sleep starts now
you know even before I saw this update
about their the them saying this is a
Shakedown he was demanding money from us
so that we wouldn't I wouldn't he
wouldn't go public
like before I read that update it's
exactly how it seemed to me
and if that's the case then this is a
guy who was uh
who was taken out of this horrible
circumstance rescued from an abusive and
neglect of how you know neglectful house
and family
uh cared for by this other family given
a chance in life
and now he's turning around
in public
and uh and throwing them under the bus
for money
which you know
even if he has some legitimate
complaints which he probably does like
in any human relationship that goes bad
there's almost always blame some kind of
blame on both sides it's very rare that
you've got a clear-cut villain and then
a clear-cut victim and the victim hasn't
done anything wrong at all doesn't
usually work that way in human
relationships
especially when there's time and money
involved
um
so even if he has some legitimate
complaints and say oh they did this they
did that whatever
you are still turning on these people
in public
throwing them under the bus crucifying
them in public people who have cared for
you and you're doing it for money
and there are
that is almost never Justified
because that's what it's all about like
he's a they're all millionaires he's a
millionaire if he's not a millionaire
millionaire anymore then he's an idiot
who managed to to waste all that money
and I don't know if that's the case
wouldn't surprise me
but
uh he was been paid millions of dollars
and he's doing this for money and even
he doesn't deny that
and it's just to me it's
just despicable hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there